bonsoir merci d'être avec nous la
décision donc de donald trump de retirer
en 2000 soldats d'afghanistan et 500
d'irak a inquiété le secrétaire général
de l'otan qui craint que l'afghanistan
devienne un refuge pour les terroristes
est ce que clairement vous partagez
cette hypothèse oui c'est une
déclaration assez inhabituel de gestes
solberg qui est en général beaucoup plus
discret mais là c'est vrai que il met le
doigt sur un problème qui est une
inquiétude qui est par rapport à la
présence de la coalition internationale
en afghanistan à douze mille hommes dont
à peu près la moitié des américains et
donc le retrait qui est annoncé par
donald trump effectivement est conforme
à ses promesses de campagne électorale
de ce point de vue là il est assez
cohérent mais s'inquiète beaucoup
beaucoup de monde y compris d'ailleurs
dans son propre camp puisque mitch
mcconnell qui est le chef de la majorité
républicaine au sénat lui même qui est
un soutien déclaré du président donald
trump a dit que ça ne le fait que les ce
retrait des troupes précipité pourrait
être une erreur et qu'il pourrait ravir
faire plaisir contenter les personnes
qui souhaitent du mal aux états unis
donc on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
des interrogations y compris dans le
camp républicain
même si c'est effectivement dans
registre des promesses qui sont qui
doivent être tenus par delattre et on
peut penser que la transition qui est
qui est en cours qui est difficile avec
la future administration joe biden c'est
aussi une manière de pour le président
donald trump de familièrement on peut
dire savonner la planche du futur
président ça veut dire en gros qu'on
aurait fait tout ça pour ça toutes ces
années
deux soldats américains sur place pour
en arriver finalement voilà presque à
zéro un repaire de terroristes dans ce
pays alors on n'en est pas là encore
mais effectivement la question est posée
bon les promesses de donald trump
c'était de mettre fin aux guerres sans
fin
c'était là déclare halal la formule qui
l'employait régulièrement il ya de ce
point de vue là il ya une cohérence par
rapport à ses propos
constant puisque il avait été amené à
faire un sort jeu contre le malgré lui
d'une certaine manière
contre l'avis de ses propres mais dieter
et puisque son intuition le pousser au
contraire un retrait donc il va jusqu'au
bout de ce retrait en le précipitant et
on peut noter que le timing était ce
intéressant parce qu'effectivement ces
cinq jours avant la passation de pouvoir
qui est prévue en janvier
donc c'est aussi une manière de préparer
sa forme de difficultés pour le futur
président joe biden
même si officiellement les les alliés
sont encore engagés mais il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations qui qui surgissent
aujourd'hui à partir du moment où ce
retrait est acté une bonne avancée ans
selon les talibans c'est la réaction des
talibans après l annonce de cette
réduction du nombre de soldats
américains sur place ce qu'on doit
voilà sans m'inquiéter de cette réaction
des talibans qui sont pas vraiment
connus pour leur modération même si les
etats-unis négocient depuis plusieurs
années avec eux oui ben n'est pas lé pa
surprenant parce que elle va d'une
certaine manière est contente leurs
attentes
on peut rappeler que dans le cadre de
l'accord de février 2020 qui avaient été
engagées avec les doigts avec les
talibans il y avait il y avait la
perspective du retrait qui était
effectivement qui devait être effectif
d'ici à mai 2021
il est accélérée donc ça ne peut que les
contenter de ce point de vue là et les
met en position de force par rapport au
gouvernement de kaboul même si ce
dernier considère que l'essentiel des
activités militaires étaient déjà de
leur fait
mais enfin en tout cas il ya quand même
il y avait quand même toujours un appui
feu aérien qui est très très
portant la nuit dans certaines
opérations récentes donc il ya de la
part du gouvernement de kaboul il ya
l'effort de ne pas montrer son
inquiétude
enfin elle est réelle et on peut le
comprendre parce qu'il ya une
accélération du calendrier qui n'est pas
en leur faveur
et qu'est-ce que ça voudra dire
concrètement pour la population afghane
sur place ce retrait américain
bah on sent on sent monter une
inquiétude un de beaucoup alors de la
population générale notamment de
certaines minorités comme et à zéro
puisque on peut rappeler que le 2
novembre dernier il ya eu encore une
attaque de dice qui était faite contre
l'université de kaboul
il ya une situation délétère qui prévaut
et même si les troupes américaines sont
plus visés puisque ça fait partie de
l'accord entre américains et est
aliments sont plus visés en tant que
tels
les troupes gouvernementales sont des
cibles qui demeurent des cibles
militaires pour les talibans donc la
situation d'être stabilisé d'ailleurs
les négociations depuis septembre sont
un peu enlisé entre entre les autorités
de kaboul et les représentants talibans
donc là on voit bien que le lien
télescopage entre le calendrier
politique américain et la réalité sur le
terrain qui dépend faveur situation
organes merci david rigoulet roze
rédacteur en chef revue orient
stratégique chercheurs socialistes
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france